NARRATOR:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
We've done $5.8 million
worth of sales.
Ba-bam!
NARRATOR: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
Bam --
What's the answer?
I will do
anything it takes.
That's not
the right answer.
You are going to die
a horrible death.
NARRATOR: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
I love the product.
It's genius.
Whoo!
...They're ready to invest
using their own money.
I'll do the dance,
but at 25%.
Whoa.
NARRATOR: And they're
willing to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
It's a teensy, weensy,
cockroach-baseball league.
It's a
$6-billion-a-year industry.
That's poo-poo.
You are not
an entrepreneur.
It's easy
for them all to say
when they've never
created a product.
You suck.
What time is selling time?
It's always selling time.
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went from
waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
is a couple with a follow-up
to a very successful product.
Hi, sharks.
My name is Matt Griffin.
And I'm his wife,
pastry chef Emily Griffin,
and we're from
Carmel, Indiana.
We own baker's edge,
and we are seeking $400,000
for 20% of our company.
We have completely
reinvented bakeware.
Everyone loves brownies,
but have you ever
stopped to think about
which brownie
is really the best?
In a normal pan
of brownies,
you have a middle and a ring
of outside-edge pieces.
And if you're like
a lot of people,
you always go for
those corners and edges first.
Realizing the edges are
where the baking magic happens,
we put on
our thinking caps
and came up with a whole new way
to make brownies.
In our pan, every brownie
has at least two chewy edges.
The pan's bottom rises up
and allows heat to evenly
circulate around every brownie,
caramelizing and edgifying
every single brownie in the pan.
For the past several years,
we have dominated the larger,
multinational brands.
We now want
to leverage that success,
and we want to launch
a line of conventional bakeware.
We think normal bakeware
can be made so much better
in both form and function.
And based upon
our current success,
we're just the company
that can get it done.
CORCORAN: Do you have a patent
on the design?
We do.
We have a utility patent
on the edge-pan design.
Everybody in the industry
said, "This is dumb.
It'll never work.
It's too new."
But we stuck with it,
and as soon as
we started making money,
people
followed the money trail.
Matt,
how successful are you?
Since we began selling
in 2006,
we've done $5.8 million
worth of sales.
You got to be kidding.
Really?
O'LEARY:
How -- How much this year?
HERJAVEC: Wow.
How much this year?
In 2012, we did
about $256,000 of sales.
So, what happened?
CUBAN: Something slowed down.
Where'd it go way up, and then
when did it go way down?
At the peak, we did
$1.7 million worth in a year.
O'LEARY: Whoa.
Wow.
$1.7 million
versus $256,000?
But $1 million of that
was in 30 days.
How?
Oprah.
Favorite things list.
Wow.
O'LEARY:
So, she blessed you
and she cursed you
at the same time...
Right.
...'Cause your comparables will
never, ever be the same again.
Right.
That's correct.
And now you're paying for it.
You took that money
and put it in the bank, right?
Oh, yeah.
I mean,
the money was great,
and we paid off
all of our debts.
I know
you've been on QVC, right?
Or you never were?
No.
Was that a competitor?
That was
an infringement,
and it's no longer sold
on QVC.
Okay, so, your infringers,
you've taken care of.
There is no infringing product
on the market.
We've swatted
all of those down.
Matt, you're not here
because of the pan.
By your own admission,
that's a flatline sale.
So, how are you gonna get back
To $1.5 million in sales?
Here's how
we're gonna do it.
We call this
our better muffin pan.
We applied kind of
our design sense
and our high quality
to a muffin pan,
and this is
what comes out.
Circles don't nest
like soldiers.
In nature, they nest
like a honeycomb.
So we nested them
You know what that does?
No.
It saves us some metal.
There's not these extra, little
table tops between the cups,
because they're
nested closer.
What it also does,
when you're filling
this thing up --
There's no place really
to spill.
It goes
in the muffin cups.
Matt, is it cheaper
than a normal muffin pan?
This is not cheaper.
This is a $35.95 product,
just like our brownie pan.
Is it easier to clean
than a normal muffin pan?
It's super-easy to clean.
That's another key.
It's one piece, no rivets
and welds, rounded corners.
So, going forward, though,
your baseline business
is $256,000 a year.
Right.
That's poo-poo.
Relative, yeah.
Okay, so why is it worth
2 million bucks?
It's worth $2 million
because we have a patent
that protects us.
We also have
a foot in the door
in an industry that has
no new entrants for years.
This is a teensy, weensy,
cockroach-baseball-league
industry.
It's a $6-billion-a-year
industry...
EMILY: It's a $6 bill--
...for bakeware.
GREINER:
You guys, this pan --
They created a pan
that truly was revolutionary.
HERJAVEC:
No, no, but, Lori...
Seven years ago.
Every single person that had
a store that sold bakeware...
Seven years ago.
...Carried your pan.
Guys, look.
You did something great
seven years ago.
It had to be obvious to you,
when the whole thing sank,
you had to be going,
"I got to do something.
I got to do something."
And then,
three years later,
you come up with
the muffin-top super pan?
Yeah, well --
What the hell
were you doing?
I'm out.
What time is selling time,
Mark?
It's always selling time.
For two years,
you've been flatlining.
I'm not taking anything away
from what you created,
but I like
to get into business with people
that have a sense
of paranoia.
In my world,
only the paranoid survive.
You are very comfortable.
I'm out.
I would disagree
with that
in terms of being paranoid
or being comfortable.
You've got to understand,
you know, we have a family
and three kids.
At the time, we had two kids.
One was a newborn.
We had 5,000 pans
in our basement.
My parents came over.
My sister came over.
We packed pans
UNTIL 4:00 in the morning.
I had a baby getting up
every two hours,
and we're packing pans
and running orders on laptops.
We've been doing this hard-core
for years.
O'LEARY: We've -- We've heard
the story of the past.
For me,
that's completely irrelevant.
I don't care about the past.
If I'm gonna put up dollars
and invest in baker's edge,
I want to know
what the future holds.
That does not feel, to me,
like it's going to change
the world for muffins.
I want to know how
I'm gonna make a lot
of money selling this.
Apparently, it's burned out.
Everybody's got one
that wants one.
That's the story of your deal.
You don't have a new idea.
Uh --
I'm sorry.
I am out.
GREINER: You know,
it's easy for them all to say
when they've never
created a product.
[ chuckles ]
Okay?
It's extremely hard
to come up with something
as revolutionary
as what you did...
It's all in the past.
...For the retails.
Listen, listen.
It doesn't matter.
What they did was great.
You know, Margaret Mitchell
wrote one novel,
but it was
"Gone With the Wind."
Does she need
to write more?
Does she still
get royalties on it?
You did something fantastic
here in creating that,
and I admire you both
because I think
that that was genius.
So, the problem is
that you do have to keep trying
to come out with more
if you're trying
to sustain a business.
I don't feel
that this is the wave.
What you're holding in your hand
doesn't strike me
to have that same uniqueness
as what the brownie pan did.
Right.
So, for that reason,
I'm going out.
CORCORAN: I want to give you
a little bit of advice.
Don't put a lot of time
into this product.
You can't afford to take
the wrong product out right now.
This is the sophomore year
in your business,
when you've got to really
get good at what you're doing
and be really careful.
And I don't think
that's careful enough.
So, I don't have
the confidence.
I sure as heck wouldn't feel
comfortable with my money in it.
So I am out.
Re-reluctantly, I'm out.
Okay.
Thanks, you guys.
Appreciate it.
Good luck, guys.
We appreciate the advice.
Thank you.
They really got fixed on
sort of a sales plateau
that we're experiencing,
and -- and they took that
as bad weather on the horizon.
They're savvy,
I respect their opinions,
but I feel like we've
still got a long way to
go with our products.
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
are mothers with a mission
of taking the pain
out of shoe shopping with kids.
Hi.
I'm Dr. Sylvie Shapiro.
And I'm Nicole Brooks.
Sharks, we are asking you
for $75,000
for a 15% stake
in Foot Fairy.
We're both moms,
and when I have to take my
four children to the shoe store,
it looks
something like this.
WOMAN:
No, that is going down!
HERJAVEC:
[ chuckles ]
[ screams ]
[ laughs ]
[ crying ]
[ laughter ]
[ girl shouts ]
Running the three bases.
[ girls screaming ]
With Foot Fairy,
you'll never have
to go through this.
Foot fairy
is an iPad app
that allows you to accurately
measure your child's foot size
in the comfort and convenience
of your own home.
I'm a podiatrist,
and parents
constantly tell me
they just guess
their child's shoe size,
and I see
so many foot problems
associated with kids
wearing the wrong size shoe.
This is my daughter
sienna,
and she'll be demoing
the app for us today.
You simply take the iPad,
place your child's foot
against it,
wait for the chime...
[ chime ]
and presto!
Your child's shoe size
is displayed.
You then have the option
of going to get shoes,
in which you'll be
linked to zappos
to a prepopulated page
of shoes in your child's size.
So, we at Foot Fairy
hope that you shark fairies
will help us
to make every mom's life
just a little bit easier.
And make sure that every child
is in a proper-fitted shoe.
Thank you, sienna.
You can go back to daddy now.
GREINER:
Thanks, sienna.
CORCORAN: Thank you.
Your app is totally done now,
but you'd use the money
to further enhance the app?
What's missing?
Oh, well, we want to build out
the back-end infrastructure,
so we'd love to be able to
store our customer e-mails.
It just really gives us a way
to encourage people
to buy shoes,
to remind them, because --
But you're not
selling them shoes, right?
Why is there an upside
for that?
We are.
Oh, actually,
that's our sales model.
Our app is free.
We have an affiliate sales model
with zappos
where we get
between 8% to 18%.
How many downloads of the app
do you have today?
13,144.
But we just launched
three weeks ago officially.
HERJAVEC: In the three weeks
you've been doing it,
have you actually gotten
a commission check from zappos?
No.
We have
a 98% click-through rate,
but we cannot
track our commission
because
there was a glitch.
It was going to the zappos app
rather than --
Have you fixed that glitch?
That's a very important glitch.
We fixed that
about three days ago.
GREINER:
That's a big click-through rate.
It was a very big one.
It's a very big click-through.
We are very excited.
GREINER: It's a very big
click-through rate.
But where are you
on the home page?
Like, I'm curious,
as you launch --
We went directly
from our app to a pre--
No, no, no.
But wait, wait, wait.
I have a question. It's,
like, getting crazy in here.
Sorry, sorry. Sorry!
HERJAVEC: Wow.
Here's my question.
Is zappos doing anything
to advertise you
so that people
are going to your app?
No. We don't need zappos
to advertise.
We are confident.
We spent $2,600
and got over 13,000 downloads
in less than 3 weeks.
Also, I mean,
another way to make money
besides
just the click-through
is we'd love to have advertising
and sponsorships.
But tell me -- Why don't they
put you on their main site?
Um...
We have such a
targeted market of moms.
If it -- If it helps --
GREINER: They should.
It's an accessory.
Well, maybe that's something
you could help us with.
It's like a help
to their customers.
We would love
to be on zappos' main site.
We would love to be.
Yeah.
Did you suggest it
in a meeting?
It's a podiatrist,
therapist mom.
[ chuckles ]
Did you suggest it?
We're here
to answer your questions.
HERJAVEC: Wow, Nicole, you're
like that dog in that movie.
When we --
Like, he's walking along
doing one thing, and he
Sees -- "Squirrel!"
[ laughter ]
I'm really committed
to this.
She is. She's --
And I'm committed --
I'm committed to showing you all
how fabulous this idea is.
And we know that
we can make you see --
CUBAN: But, n-Nicole --
O'LEARY:
Why aren't you telling me
about something proprietary
or a patent or a technology
or software no one can emulate?
We're the propri--
We are the -- I'm a podiatrist.
You're -- You're it?
L-ladies, if it works --
If it works
and you get 10,000 orders...
We're n-- We're gonna get
500,000 downloads at least.
Okay. You're -- You're dead
before that happens.
And each --
You had a great idea.
There's nothing proprietary
About it -- Bang! --
The guys that care
are gonna emulate this.
No, actually,
they can't.
Because what you have here
is expertise and passion.
I'm out.
GREINER:
You know what?
I've never seen somebody
so exuberant about what
they're doing as the two of you.
For me, it's not a business yet.
You're just at the very start.
I'm out.
HERJAVEC:
Nicole, I love the excitement.
When you first came out,
I thought it was a great idea.
And my first thought was,
"Wow, I can't believe this isn't
On the zappos website today."
So, the question is
is it such a difficult
technology to create
that nobody else could do it?
CUBAN:
Who wrote the software?
We have a tech-- Technology team
that worked with both of us.
To create --
And where'd you get
your technology team?
Where did we
get them from?
Yeah.
We researched it,
and we found them.
We -- Yeah.
But, Sylvie, do you realize,
by virtue of that answer,
if you were able to, as
non-programming-computer people,
find somebody who could write
it, I-it could be duplicated.
You know what?
Anything can be duplicated.
But -- But I guess, there's
nothing proprietary with it.
No, Robert.
Please don't say that.
[ laughter ]
I'm out.
So, that -- That leaves
Barbara and Mark.
CORCORAN: I think, uh,
you're a perfect example
of, "Enthusiasm is not enough."
You're wildly enthusiastic,
but that's where it ends.
It's a wild card.
I don't know
if it's gonna work,
whether you can
make money on it.
Um, so I couldn't
possibly invest.
I'm out.
And now -- Now we've left
with mister....Mr. Mark.
Um, if some world-renowned
podiatrist walked in the door
and you had
to defend the product
and why it's better than
something this world-renowned
podiatrist could create,
what would you say?
Because this is
what I'm passionate about.
CUBAN:
No, forget passion.
T-this --
That's not the right answer.
I'm trying to figure out
what differentiates you.
Okay.
And if I hear the word
"passion" again, I'm out.
'Cause I already know
you're passionate.
The longer the backstory,
the worse the business.
So, world-famous podiatrist
walks in the door
and says,
"Okay, Dr. Foot Mom,
why is yours better
than something I can create?"
Right.
So -- bam --
what's the answer?
NARRATOR:
Four sharks are out.
Sylvie and Nicole
have one more chance for a deal.
So, world-famous podiatrist
walks in the door
and says,
"Okay, Dr. Foot Mom,
"why is yours better
than something I can create?
What is it
that you brought?"
Right.
So -- bam --
what's the answer?
Accuracy.
Why is your accuracy going
to be better than somebody --
Because we spent
over a year
determining
how to make this
the most accurate
shoe-sizing app.
So,
if I did a search for
"app that determines
child's foot size,"
trying to get
a feel for the competition,
what would I see?
You would see ours.
Foot fairy.
What else?
You would see
a couple other apps.
And what I-- And what about
theirs is different than yours?
The mom has
to put the child's foot
and then slide their finger
on it.
BROOKS: A lot of room
for parental error.
It's not as accurate.
We really wanted ours
to be convenient and accurate.
That's why we
went to shopping malls
and had kids test it.
Got it. Got it.
Here --
Here's why I'm interested.
I have a company called
fashion metric,
and they did a whole exhaustive
analysis just on men's shirts.
So,
if you're this body type,
this is the shirt
that fits you in this manner
versus that manner.
Sensors and metrics, I think,
are gonna be huge in the future.
So I like this.
Mm-hmm.
My fear?
You guys
will drive me batty.
They'll put me
in the loony bin, right?
We would love to work with you.
I mean, we really would.
And we -- We won't
drive you batty.
We -- We'll work together,
we will, you know -- we'll
seek any of your advice
that you have.
I mean, I really, really
want to get this to parents.
We really believe, as you said,
that is the future,
that we want to be a --
People to sit in the comfort
of their own home
and be able to have --
Purchase things
that fit them properly
that are for their health
and for their aesthetic.
I'll offer you $100,000...
...For 40%,
but I'm gonna put
contingencies on it, okay?
One -- I get to go through
and test to make sure it works.
Absolutely.
Two--
I get to go through and check
to make sure that
there's nothing comparable.
Three -- I'm gonna
check all the contracts
to make sure that we truly
do own the software,
and that it's well-written.
So, it's 100k, 40%.
Yes or no?
Yes.
Done.
Thank you.
And if I need therapy,
I get to call it off.
[ laughs ]
Yeah.
That would be
a door relationship...
Thanks, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
...So I couldn't --
I couldn't engage in that.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you.
GREINER: Congratulations.
Good luck.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
High five?
[ both squeals ]
We're so excited that we're
gonna be working with Mark.
[ cheering ]
SHAPIRO: I mean, this is,
like, really a dream come true.
Mr. Cuban,
to work with him --
I-I couldn't have asked
for a better shark.
NARRATOR: This season, we've
seen amazing success stories
from our "Shark Tank"
entrepreneurs.
Whoa! Wow!
DYER:
Business has really taken off
since making a deal
with Kevin and Robert.
We're coming up on half
a million dollars in revenue.
YOUNG: Since partnering with
Lori, in less than eight months,
we've done over $3 million
in sales.
Those aren't projections.
Those are real numbers.
TSELIKIS: We're so lucky to have
made a deal with Barbara.
Just a year later,
we're approaching
$3.5 million in sales.
CUBAN:
What's up, Doug?
MARSHALL:
Making a deal with Mark and Lori
changed our life
beyond our wildest dreams.
MAN: Going on "Shark Tank" has
taken a small, little product
that was run out of my apartment
and made it into
a multimillion-dollar company.
This is a great start,
but this is just the beginning.
I am so proud of you.
Thank you so much, Mom.
One day, I hope to be
the best company in America
for women to work for.
As far as women have come
in the corporate world,
I think there's still
a long ways to go,
and I want to be the one
to make that change happen.
CHILD:
Since "Shark Tank,"
we've done almost $6 million
in sales nationwide.
We like to think
that we're continuing
the tradition
of American innovation.
It's awesome to be able
to create jobs
and provide a living wage
for lots of employees.
CAMERON:
Manufacturing has been gone
for a long time in this state.
But we're bringing it back.
O'LEARY: There's never been
anything like "Shark Tank."
It's the most powerful
venture-capital firm on Earth.
It has sharks, it has money,
and it has millions of people
watching.
When you put all of
those together, magic happens.
QUACKENBUSH:
Our "Shark Tank" experience
has been a roller coaster
of emotion.
To think that
we started in a street tent --
And now what the future
holds for us just blows us away.
WHITEMAN: Each morning, I've
woken up, I've pinched myself.
I just can't believe
this is really happening,
and I just can't wait to see
what happens in the future.
KRUMINS: It brings me to tears
thinking about how proud I am
to show my daughter
that you can do this,
that you can follow your dreams.
I'm truly touched.
Thank you.
NARRATOR:
Next into the tank
are entrepreneurs
with a simple solution
to a tedious
and time-consuming problem.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Wayne sikorcin.
My name is Scott Smith.
Our company is Tie-Not,
and we're here today
seeking $125,000
of your hard-earned money
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
Tie-Not was invented
to cure an epidemic
that occurs worldwide
every year
from sore fingers from tying
these tiny water balloons.
We're excited today, sharks,
to show you two of our items --
The Tie-Not filler
and the Tie-Not tying stick.
With these two items,
anyone and everyone
can simply fill and tie
water balloons in seconds.
Ba-bam!
O'LEARY: Oh, yeah, that's --
That's pretty cool.
CORCORAN:
Pretty cool.
GREINER:
Wow. Yeah.
So, now even
"Sausage-Fingers" Smith
can now tie
these little water balloons.
Oh, gosh!
[ laughter ]
Just in case you missed it,
you take our Tie-Not filler --
It attaches
to any garden hose --
And you insert
the Tie-Not stick.
The stick is universal 'cause
you can tie the water balloons
by the stick
by hand, also.
I want to try it.
Let me load it up
for you, Kev.
I have
to load it myself.
I have to learn
'cause I just bought it.
You're not at the store.
SIKORCIN:
Slip on a balloon.
Now tilt it forward.
[ laughter ]
I tilt it forward, right?
Push your piston down.
The orange piston
fills the balloon.
All right.
Now what? I just --
Swing it
around the stick.
CUBAN: Oh, my God.
There you go.
Now pull it off and put it
through the top of the slot.
Let go.
Pull the balloon
straight off.
Did it work?
GREINER:
It worked.
Voilà!
And he even wrapped it around
several times.
CUBAN: TA-da!
Very cool.
Kevin.
[ gasps ]
Oh!
[ laughter ]
Oh! I didn't see that coming.
If that had broken,
I'd kill you.
That was...
SIKORCIN: Now we're ready
for your questions.
Can we see them?
Well, yes, you can.
[ laughs ]
Okay.
So, you got one packaged
and you got one loose.
I kept it loose so you
can appreciate the
technology behind it.
Thank you.
So, you were saying that you
don't have to own both things.
You can just have
the stick...
You can just have the stick.
...Or you can have
the filling device, too?
Yes, correct.
CORCORAN: What do you miss
when you just have the stick?
GREINER:
So, the stick would work
if you did it out of your sink?
Yes.
So, how did you
come up with the idea?
What it was is, my wife
bought 250 water balloons
for a family picnic
back in 2008,
and I got the tedious task
of tying these things.
My kids couldn't tie them.
So, I tied like 15.
Kids ripped through it
in like two seconds,
and I said,
"I'm done."
But I wasn't done
thinking about the problem.
So every day after work,
I'd come home, I'd sketch,
and one day, my daughter Abby
looks at one of my sketches,
and says,
"That looks like a stick."
So she goes and grabs a stick,
brings it in to me.
I carve out
a little pocket and a slot,
we go outside
and tied a water balloon.
Hmm.
And I was like,
"Whoa. It just tied."
So then I followed
all the proper procedures.
We went
for patents first.
So, I built an eight-cavity mold
after the patents issued,
and we made it
to the toy fair in 2010.
And that's where
we launched our product.
What did you sell of it?
First year?
$112,000.
Yeah.
Good for you.
What does this sell for?
It sells for $4.99,
and it comes with 50 balloons.
And what's your cost
to make the entire package?
Uh, it's about $1.50
right now.
Why isn't this product
Sort of $7.99?
Why does it have to be $4.99?
[ chuckling ]
We asked the same question.
We started out at $9.99,
and we sold a boatload of them.
Then what happened
to that price?
Well...
We got into
a licensing agreement
with a large toy company.
What was your percentage
on the licensing agreement?
6%.
Kevin, what do you
think about that?
You know, thank goodness
you've met me.
[ laughter ]
'Cause you got
a low-end deal.
7% to 11% is the range.
What were your total sales last
year, including the licensing?
$340-- With the licensing,
$385,000.
But you still have
the license agreement in place?
Yes, we do.
It's in place.
When --
Is there minimums on it?
Yes, there are.
Yes.
And they're hitting -- Obviously
hitting their minimums.
Is there an escalator
in the minimums every year?
No, there's no escalator.
Oh!
Oh, you're
such a bad negotiator.
Ooh.
And how many more years --
How much longer does it go?
Well, it renews
every year.
Oh, oh, really?
Autorenew or you can --
Yeah, we didn't want to
lock in anything long term.
So can you cancel it
at your option?
Oh, yeah. We got like, what is
it, a 90-day out of jail?
CORCORAN: You're kidding?
Cancel it.
We have a 60-day
get-out-of-jail agreement.
Oh, that's cool.
O'LEARY:
You know, l-look.
Your cash flows don't justify
your $1.25 million valuation.
That's the problem.
You're overpricing
your value right now.
If you license it with all
the players, it was never --
Yeah, but you're asking me
to pay
for what I can
bring the business to now.
It's -- It's not interesting
for me.
Yeah, I could add a lot of
value, but I got to wet my beak.
I understand.
That's a big,
old beak, too.
Yeah.
Guys, look -- Kevin's
the toy maven, I'm not.
I think it's great.
You guys deserve
a ton of credit.
I-it really is
an ingenious product.
SMITH: Whoo!
SIKORCIN: Whoo!
Whoo!
GREINER: [ chuckles ]
I'm out.
[ laughter ]
Thank you
for the opportunity.
Absolutely.
Hey, guys, I-I love --
I love the toy business.
And I like businesses that
bring a smile to your face...
Yes.
...And make me happy
and make money.
Yes.
But your --
Your value's a little crazy.
$1.25 million?
I-it's not there today.
I'm out.
Thank you
for the opportunity.
We appreciate it.
You know, for me,
this is a perfect QVC product.
It really, really is.
GREINER: Actually, it --
You know what?
It really kind of isn't
because it's
too inexpensive, actually,
to be a good QVC product.
You have to be really more in
like a $12 or $15 price range.
Just tell them
it's genius.
Whoo!
[ laughter ]
Oh, is that
the key word?
It's genius.
SIKORCIN: Whoo!
[ laughter ]
It's genius.
Whoo!
Now you're
playing with us.
Believe me,
our wives hate it.
To me, just the valuation,
I-it's not there for me.
You're not at $1.25 million.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Let me ask you this.
Where would you value us?
What did you make
on $380,000?
What'd you make last --
$40,000.
And how much you p--
You guys paying each other?
Or, yourselves?
Well, we're
building a brand,
so no one's taking
any money out of it.
Nothing's
taken out of it.
So, that's $40,000
before you took a penny out.
That's correct.
Yeah.
So it's $40,000?
Why so low?
Where did all the money go?
Trade shows.
We're always marketing,
right?
Guys, I've been in the toy
industry a long, long time.
A business like this
will be at five-times cash flow,
you're worth about $200,000.
So you're not worth
$1.25 million.
That's reality.
Where I would have
loved to have seen this product
was before you did that
license deal, 'cause
that's my specialty.
I really can't help you
that much.
It's not big enough for me.
I like big.
How do you get big
without a strategic partner?
Yeah. I'm sorry, guys.
I'm out.
You know, it's a hard one,
because I love the product.
Because I have probably blown up
5 million water balloons.
I'm the go-to mom in the
neighborhood in the summertime.
We just gave you
more margarita time.
Absolutely.
[ laughter ]
Oh, good.
Now, I'll make you an offer.
I'm gonna give you the $125,000
for 25% of your business.
Wow.
SIKORCIN:
That's fair.
O'LEARY: Incredible offer.
Wait.
Yeah. Very good.
But I'm gonna give it to you
in the form of $50,000 cash,
$75,000 credit line.
I think where we're at
is we're more comfortable
with an 18% offer...
...The $50,000 in cash
and $100,000 in credit line
to move us into next year.
Because we are
really gonna need inventory,
so that's where I'm gonna need
to really tap into resources.
Wow.
Well, bring it on down,
baby.
[ laughter ]
I'm gonna give you
a chance to reconsider.
You've heard my offer.
You know the Shark Tank.
You obviously know
what I could bring to the table.
So I'm not going
to negotiate that.
Okay, can you
Work a little bit -- 20%?
We got a deal right now.
Lock hands, we do
the dance together, 20%.
I don't think so.
I think I'll stay
with what I offered.
Whoa.
She's tough.
I'm not tough.
I'll do the dance,
but at 25%.
If I do the dance,
will you do it at 20%?
[ laughter ]
Um...
Honestly,
I can't come there.
All right, I'm out.
All right.
Good luck.
I can't believe
they didn't take your offer.
It was a decent offer.
Hey, I like when entrepreneurs
stick their ground and
believe in their value.
SIKORCIN: Although Barbara's
offer was very fair,
we just needed to see eye to eye
on the equity value,
and she took too much.
Tie-Not has
a huge growth potential.
My name is Kaeya Majmundar.
I'm from Chicago, Illinois,
and I'm a sophomore
at Emory University.
[ all chanting in Hindi ]
I was raised in a very
traditional Indian family.
Both my parents are doctors,
and it was always their dream
for me to become a doctor
as well.
Good job.
My childhood summers
were spent practicing violin
and going to the library
and taking math classes.
But it wasn't weird to me,
because that's what all my
Indian friends were doing.
But then I got to college,
and I saw
all these different people
studying different things,
and that excited me.
When I came up with
my fabulous idea,
I knew at that moment
that I had to pursue it.
Creating my product
was actually the easy part.
The hard part
was telling my parents
I no longer
wanted to be a doctor.
I know it's been tough
for you guys.
I'm gonna
make you guys proud, I promise.
My parents had a path for me,
but I completely changed it.
There's a lot of pressure
to succeed,
and failure's not an option.
I want to channel
the hard-work ethic
that my parents and
my grandparents taught me,
and I want to make
my own American dream.
And I need the sharks to do it.
Hi, sharks.
My name is Kaeya Majmundar,
and I'm a sophomore
at Emory University.
My product is bzbox,
and I am seeking $50,000 in
exchange for 20% of my company.
So, this all started after
my freshman year of college.
My friend had asked me to move
her boxes to our storage unit
while she took her chem final.
I agreed, of course,
so I went over,
and I saw her boxes
ready to go by the door.
But as I leaned in
to pick one of them up...
...Everything literally
fell straight through.
That amounted to a long day
of me having to repack
and move all of her stuff.
I decided I had to find
a solution.
That's when I innovated
the bzbox.
Now, Robert,
you're a connoisseur for racing,
so I'm gonna challenge you
to a race today.
So why don't you
come on up here?
Make sure he doesn't
crash your deal.
[ chuckles ]
I thought you were gonna
knock yourself out, there.
So, Robert is going to
assemble the traditional box
that you would buy
from any hardware store,
and I'm gonna
assemble my bzbox.
So, Mark, why don't you
give us your Mark,
and Robert and I
are gonna race.
Are you --
Are you ready?
Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa. hang on.
What am I doing?
Am I putting this --
You've probably never
assembled a box, have you?
[ laughter ]
Yeah, the truth comes out.
I'm so rich, I hired Kevin
to put boxes together for me.
Oh, my goodness.
On your Mark...
...Get set...
...Go!
All right, I'm done.
Oh! You were whupped.
You suck.
Do it again.
I didn't see it.
All right,
I can do it again.
I just unassembled it,
and now I'm gonna
assemble it again.
Bam, done.
Pretty nice.
MAJMUNDAR: So, sharks,
my flat-folding design
is ideal for anyone
who is looking for a unique,
space-saving, easy-to-use,
and, might I add,
sexy storage solution.
With your expertise
and my drive,
we can target
every houseware, homeware,
craft store, storage store --
You name it.
Man, I'm excited!
'Cause this product,
it will revolutionize
the packing industry.
So, have you done any retail
selling of this product yet?
I have not.
This is brand-new.
I started it
less than a year ago.
I'm a sophomore in college,
and so, I-I thought about it
last year.
What is the cost of your box
versus that box?
If you were looking at,
say, 10,000 units,
the cost for a traditional one
would be under $1.
This one will be $1.75.
Does it ever
get to the same price?
It will with -- With
larger quantities, of course.
You know, I have sold hundreds
of thousands of those boxes
to consumers
in my storage facilities.
That box is actually made
for about 56 cents.
Yeah, I -- My -- My estimate
was for the 10,000 units.
CORCORAN: Do you mind
going back for me?
What is your background?
Yeah, so, I was actually
raised in a family of doctors.
I'm Indian.
Yes, the stereotype is true.
Aww.
My whole family said,
"You know what?
"You're a woman.
You're Indian.
"You cannot do anything
other than medicine
because you're not
gonna make it."
And I said,
"No, absolutely not."
And when I confronted
my parents,
all he-- heck broke loose.
[ laughs ]
It was truly
a-a huge moment in my life.
CORCORAN:
So what happened?
You said,
"Boxes are for me, Mom"?
Yeah, and they laughed.
It was a joke.
It was a joke in my family.
They say, you know, "What do you
want to do with your life?"
And I say, "I want
to be my own boss.
"I have this excellent product,
I have faith,
And I'm going to do it."
Then I signed up to be in
the collegiate entrepreneurs'
organization competition.
That is the largest national
competition for entrepreneurs.
I ended up
winning the competition.
HERJAVEC:
Wow, congratulations.
Congratulations.
And my parents were like,
"Wow. All right."
Did you
file a patent on this?
Uh, yes.
It's patent pending.
I see you have other boxes
up there.
Yes.
Can you show me
the red box?
It's out of plastic?
Plastic, yes.
Yeah.
I'd like to see
how flat that folds down.
One of the things --
It sounds like you've
tried to do some pricing...
Yes.
...To see how this would
price out in the market.
Yes.
Adding this little velcro piece
is very expensive, right?
Yes. Mm-hmm.
Why can't that be done
with another material?
Perhaps another
strip of cardboard?
GREINER:
Well, velcro's super-strong.
It's expensive.
Do you think people are willing
to pay a premium for your box
to knock about 60 seconds
out of their day?
CUBAN:
I don't know.
Absolutely.
O'LEARY: Because that's
the crux of your deal.
Yeah, I don't see it.
Absolutely.
Kaeya, what about
another application?
Have you gone to any large
businesses and met with them?
Yes.
I was approached
by an executive at Lowe's.
They absolutely
loved the product.
Did Lowe's say to you,
"I will buy this product"?
Yes. He said,
"Let's get them into Lowe's."
Did he tell you
how many he would buy?
How many stores
he would put it into?
No, because at that point
in time I wasn't manufacturing.
But he said, "Come back to me.
Let's get it into Lowe's."
I had a meeting in Illinois
at shore's supply stores,
went to the C.E.O.,
and he loved it, as well.
And so, he said
that he will put me in touch
with all of his contacts.
CUBAN: Hopefully,
at some point, you said,
"How many
are you gonna buy?"
Yeah.
What was his response?
He said he was
interested in buying the box,
but he said I would have
to bring it down to be under $1.
Now, what that tells you
is they don't value the utility
more than
their current product.
If they did, they would say,
"I'll pay a penny more."
When I went to go, I wasn't
far enough in the process.
I need to get multiple orders
to match the prices
that they're interested in.
O'LEARY:
So, here's the question.
Can you make it and do you know
at what volumes you'd need
to match the pricing?
What would it take to
get the price down to 56 cents?
It would be
about 400,000 units.
Kaeya, look, I think you've
done a great presentation.
At your age,
I couldn't have stood up here
and presented to
the five of us,
but I don't see the problem
that this solution is fixing.
I'm out.
Thank you, Robert.
Think about this.
You're getting ready
for Christmas.
You have
tons of ornaments downstairs.
They're gonna
clutter your space and --
CUBAN:
You're overthinking.
You've got a solution
and you're trying to
find the problem, okay?
The pain point you solve
is time.
You have to find places
where time is money.
At home, for picking up for
Christmas, time is not money.
Packing up for school,
time is not money.
I respect your opinion,
but I-I must say
that time is always money.
Not --
You're always going to want
a more efficient, more --
A neater way, a more
efficient way to do things.
In fact, you can use it
over and over again.
A-as I listen to you, do --
Do you have it in you
to listen to advice
from somebody else
that maybe you're wrong?
That maybe there is
another way to be successful?
I just sense
that you are that way.
That I'm --
Often, the raw emotion
eventually spills out.
And maybe it's that
you believe so much
that you can dominate
this market with a
more expensive box.
I think people up here
have told you you can't do that.
Well, then, I am very much
open to your suggestions.
I am here to partner with you.
If you feel that you have
a better way to do it,
I am going to go all in.
I will do whatever it is
that you want me to do.
If you tell me to jump,
I won't ask you how high.
I'll pull out the trampoline
and I'll --
Right.
But, at some point,
you got to get the money.
You've got
to close the deal.
You've got to go find somebody
who's willing to write a check.
But right now,
that person is not me.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
You're welcome.
Barbara, Lori, Kevin?
CORCORAN: Um,
a couple things, Kaeya.
You have
a wonderful idea,
but you lack two traits that
every great entrepreneur has.
One is the ability
to listen.
The other thing is,
an entrepreneur,
by instinct, whenever
they have an opportunity
and someone says --
The Lowe's guy, what did he say?
"I want your box."
The only answer you give
as an entrepreneur
is, "Yes, sir.
How many?"
And then you find a way
to get it.
But you weren't ready.
I am -- I'm listening.
I understand.
You don't mind if I speak
quite bluntly to you, right?
You are not
an entrepreneur.
I'm out.
You don't mind if I speak
quite bluntly to you, right?
You are not
an entrepreneur.
I'm out.
Now, I am worried
about what Barbara said
'cause I felt
the same thing myself.
You just don't listen.
But I like your idea.
I believe
that if your box
was the same price as
what I sell my customers now,
they would buy yours
instead.
So, this challenge is all about
getting your price down.
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you the $50,000.
I want 50%.
[ scoffs ]
50% --
I'm your partner.
And I have no idea how much
trouble it's going to be
to get the price down
to 56 cents.
That's gonna be
your only task for me
after I give you
that $50,000.
I want you to go out
and figure it out
and come back to me
when it's 56 cents.
Are you willing
to do that?
Is that the only offer
that I'm going to get?
It may be.
I don't know.
Lori?
For me, there's some problems
with this.
Come on, Lori.
I think it's really clever.
You're really smart.
And I like that you say,
"I'll jump as high as you want,"
because that's the kind of
person that I like to work with.
Just try it with me, Lori.
It -- [ sighs ]
Please. just, please.
You are a genius,
and I know it.
I know everything
about the companies
that you've worked with.
If it's going
to get off the ground,
I know that you're the partner
that I need.
I-I promise you
you will not regret it.
You will get your money back.
I am -- I am the partner
for you.
I'm out.
You never say that
when you're negotiating
after you've got an offer.
'Cause you don't know
what the outcome is.
You made a huge mistake.
Please, Lori, please.
Just listen to me.
I will work for you.
I will listen to you.
I will do anything it takes.
I will get you your money back.
Kaeya...
...I'm gonna
make you an offer.
The offer's
going to be this --
$50,000,
40% of the business,
contingent on
if we can figure out
how to manufacture this
as a storage box.
'Cause it's got problems.
But you are the kind of person
I like to work with
because I know that you will do
whatever it takes to get there
no matter what.
It's really gonna be
something to figure out,
but I'm willing to take
the journey with you.
Lori, you have a deal.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
We'll figure it out.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[ sniffles ]
CUBAN: She would have
benefited a whole lot more
by going through this herself
'cause she's so smart
she would have learned more
by figuring it out.
But she'll also
learn a lot from me.
Oh, I'm sure she will.
I thought --
You know,
sometimes it's better
to be able to learn
from a good mentor
than to fall
on your face.
The truth is, unless you can
make these boxes for 56 cents,
you will sell zero.
We'll see down the road,
you know?
You're braver than I am.
I couldn't have done it.
What happened?
I got a deal.
Oh, you did?
Oh, I'm so happy.
Awesome.
What happened?
Who did you get it with?
Lori.
Are you serious?
We're so happy for you.
MAJMUNDAR: Lori believe in me
and believed in my product,
and Lori and I are gonna
make this the best
product it will be.